So here's the dimensionality trick.
All right?
And the notation that I've,
I'm showing you here comes
directly from the paper Turk and
Pentland I'll mention later
that does eigenfaces.
But it'll be clear.
Let's suppose each this
cap phi i is a face image.
So it's really long, all right,
d long, and by the way let's
assume we subtracted the mean.
Okay, so we've actually removed the mean
from all the pictures that we have, and
so, we're,
we've got the mean at the origin, fine.
All right.
So now let's define
a new matrix called C,
which is just the average
of AA of phi of
the sum of phi phi transpose.
Okay, this is the sum of
all the outer products and
in fact this can be written
as AA transpose if A,
this is just what it says here, is just
the stacked up face images, right?
So A, as the stacked up face images,
its going to be d, really big,
by M,
M is however many face images I have.
So its huge by reasonable,
that's what A is.
And that means AA transpose, so if I
take d by M times M by d, I get a what?
d by d, all right, d by d,
that is a really big matrix, okay?
So if d was 10,000,
this would be a 10,000 by 10,000 matrix.
How big is that, Megan?
>> A lot.
>> That's a lot, exactly.
That's a, a, a, a hundred million.
Okay?
So if it,
if it was a million long vector, a d by
d would be a million times a million.
Which would be a million million,
which is a big number.
That's a thousand billion,
which is a trillion.
That's a lot,
you wouldn't ever want to do that, okay?
The idea of trying to
find the eigenvectors of
a ten thousand by ten thousand matrix
is painful, even on today's computers.
And of a million by a million matrix,
is even more painful.
But fortunately, you don't have to.
So C equal to AA transpose
is a huge matrix.
But now, instead of considering AA
transpose, consider A transpose A.
That's only an M by M matrix, right?
because remember, A is d by M,
so A transpose A is M by M.
Finding the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of that, pretty easy.
Well, suppose I've got some
eigenvector v i that's an eigenvector
of A transpose A.
So if it's an eigenvector
of A transpose A,
that means when I multiply
A transpose A times v i,
I just get some multiplier,
lambda of v i, the eigenvalue.
Premultiply that equation by A.
When you do that,
now I got AA transpose, and
I made this blue to make
the difference clear.
A v i, and by the way I just pulled
the lambda out on the right hand side,
it's just a scalar, I can do that.
Look at that equation, what do you see?
What do you see?
What you see is that the A v i's
are the eigenvectors of AA transpose.
Remember AA transpose is that big,
ugly matrix, C?
So all we needed to do
is to find the v i's,
which are the eigenvectors
of the A transpose A,
premultiply them by the matrix A and
I now have the eigenvectors
of AA transpose.
All right.
So what this basically meant was we took
the we took the eigenvectors of an n by
n matrix and created
The eigenvectors of a d by d matrix,
without having to explicitly
compute the eigenvectors of d by d.
This is much easier to compute.